in a recent video i made about the
so-called order of assassins
i talked about the nizari ismailis
the largest group of ismaili shiites
today
but as i hinted in that video there are
also other
communities of ismailis today the
daodiboras
in india number in at almost a million
adherents today and are part of a
larger branch of ismailism
known as tabi ismailism and there is to
this branch that we turn today
to further explore the complex world
teachings ideas and practices of
ismailism shiism and islam
more generally
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this video is a collaboration with the
excellent historical channel hikmah
history
who is currently doing a series on the
fartimids
one of the most significant shia
dynasties in history
so be sure to go check out his channel
subscribe and watch the videos on the
fatimids
before watching this one because indeed
the fatimids are a central part of this
story
here is hikmah history himself to tell
you more about it
the fatimids were an ismaili shia empire
that ruled vast areas from their base in
cairo
egypt they emerged as a result of a
revolutionary movement in north africa
started by abdullah al-mahdi billah who
claimed to be the rightful imam of the
ismailis
and thus the successor to prophet
muhammad
the fatimid state quickly spread across
north africa
and beyond they founded the capital city
of cairo
from which they ruled vast areas in the
10th
11th and 12th centuries
during the height of their power the
fatimids were a mighty
empire that seriously rivaled the
abbasids in baghdad
they have become known for their art
architecture
scientific advancements and for showing
a relative tolerance
towards religious minorities
this great empire lasted for almost
three centuries
until political instability led to a
decline in influence
in the end they were overthrown in 1171
by salahuddin
ayubi if you want to know more about the
fatimids
check out the two-part documentary that
i did on them on my channel
hikmah history i have already given the
basic history and origins of the ismaili
shiites in previous videos
which you can check out for more
information but in brief the ismailis
are the second
largest branch of shia islam and with
the fatimids the ismailis came to have
great political power
the caliphs or leaders of this empire
were also the religious leaders or imams
of the ismaili shiites and served the
double function of
caliph imams the position of the imam
is central to the shiites being the
representative
heir to the prophet muhammad and the
absolute authority in all religious
matters
and this is where the different groups
of shiites differ
they disagree on which line of imams is
the correct one
and there have been several schisms in
history where people have disagreed on
who the rightful successor to a certain
imam is one such schism was between the
largest twelver shiites and the ismailis
back in the eighth century another as we
talked about in my previous video
was after the death of the fatimid
caliph imam al-mustansir in
1094. some supported his oldest son
nizar and therefore became known as the
nizadi ismailis
this is the group that established the
order of assassins in persia and syria
and is today the largest group of
ismailis being led by their 49th
imam shah kareem al-husseini or the agga
khan
iv another group however
thought that the successor to
al-mustansit was in fact his
other son al-mustaili who actually
became the next caliph
while nizad was killed and this is where
things get even more complicated
the supporters of almost ali were
further divided very shortly afterwards
when his successor
al-arabi ahmallah was assassinated by
the nizaris in 1130
al-amir was succeeded on the fatimid
throne by his
cousin al-hafiz something that was
greatly contested by a lot of ismailis
some supported al-hafiz as the new imam
and became known as the
hafizzi ismailis this group continued to
support the remaining three caliph imams
until the fatimid empire was deposed
by saladin and shortly after this
although there have been
some minor groups of half-asses
surviving they basically disappeared
so to make things easier you don't
really have to think any more about the
hafezi ismailis
they serve an important part of the
story but they are not what we will talk
about today
instead there was another group who
rejected al-hafiz as the successor to
al-amir
and instead considered his then infant
son
attab to be the well the rightful
successor
and they thus became known as the taibi
ismailis
and they still today make up a
significant community
while the largest nizari ismailies still
have a
living known imam in the agar khan
the taibis considered allamar's infant
son
atayeb to have gone into hiding and that
all subsequent imams after him have
remained in hiding and
unknown to the public instead the taibi
community has been led by a
da'i al-mutlaq a chief da'i or
chief missionary who acts as a kind of
representative for the hidden imam
and guides the community after the
schism and the fall of the fatimid
empire
the taibi ismailis established a
significant community in
yemen which would remain the base of
their activities for the following
centuries
it is in yemen that the chief dais lived
and where the majority of the community
lived as well being both politically and
intellectually active
the tabis in yemen would produce
literature and
on ismaili philosophy a smiley doctrine
and would also
develop it even further they sometimes
came into conflict with the
zaidi shiites in yemen as well as with
other groups and sometimes had very
serious political ambitions
the da al-mutlaq would also send minor
dice or
missionaries to spread the taibi ismaili
cause to other parts of the world
primarily to india where this missionary
activity was actually very successful
so successful in fact that only a few
centuries later
the taibu community in the gujarat
region of india
had surpassed the community in yemen in
terms of numbers
these indian tabes started being called
boras
which probably comes from a word meaning
traitor since the community consisted
mostly of traitors
the community in india primarily in
gujarat eventually became the new base
of operation for the taybees generally
they experienced periods of great
persecution and oppression under some
dynasties in the region
primarily by sunni muslims there are
some examples where the borders were
forced to practice takriya
in other words of hiding their religious
identity and outwardly practicing
sunnism
in order to avoid persecution on the
other hand there were also periods like
under the
mughals for example where the borders
were allowed a certain religious freedom
and could practice openly so as usual
things differed from period to period
but it is with the rising prominence of
the indian taibis
that we see the next major split in the
wider community in the 16th century
a split that created the basic outline
of the abysmalism as it stands today
in general the taibi ismailis today
exist in three
separate branches the daodi boras
the suleimanis and the alawi boras
as is often the case in the history of
shiism this split originates in
conflicts of succession
but this time it was not about the
succession of the imam
since the imams are still hidden
according to the tibis
but instead a conflict over who the
correct da
al mutlaq was after the universally
agreed
26th die there were two different
claimants to succession
and suleiman ibn hassan the former
was generally supported by the community
in india
and they thus became known as the
dawoody boras
they later was instead supported by the
majority of babies in
yemen and became known as the sulemanis
a few decades later there was another
subgroup created from the tawdiboras
which became known as the alawi borders
and while there are some daoudis living
in yemen and minor suryamani communities
in india
this general division lasts until today
the taibi ismailis in yemen generally
belong to the suleimani branch
while those in india are mostly daudi
boras or alawi boras
the daoudiboras are by far the largest
of these groups today
with some estimates showing that there
might be as many as a million adherents
this community has become a bit more
visible in the last few years and are
somewhat famous for their cuisine and
colorful clothes
the daodi boras are currently led by
their 53rd dail mutlaq
mufaddal saifuddin who like all previous
chief dice
acts as the current representative of
the hidden imam and thus holds the
greatest authority
the borders are often active
participants in society
many of its adherents are philanthropic
business people and successful traders
and there is a very high rate of
literacy and education within the
community
the boras including both the udiboras
and the alawi borahs
have primarily been located in india
around the gujarat region and in karachi
in
pakistan and so as a result of this they
have often adopted certain
indian cultural traits
for example the boras speaks a language
known as lysan
al-dawat which is a combination of
gujarati
arabic urdu and persian as mentioned
earlier other cultural characteristics
include the unique dress code of the
buddhas
the women will often wear a beautiful
dress called the
rida which is usually very colorful and
decorative
similarly the boras have a very strong
food culture the practice and contents
of which have also become quite famous
the alawi boras carry many similarities
as we have seen
but are currently led by their own dail
mutlaq by the name of
hatim zakiyudeen and when it comes to
these suleimanis the branch of
thaibius mayalism that is most common in
yemen
it's hard to say anything definitive
about them because so
little is actually known about this
community they reside mostly in northern
yemen
and have sometimes been in conflict with
the wahhabis in saudi arabia as well as
zaidi shiites within yemen itself these
suleimanies being mostly confined to
yemen
can appear quite different from the
border communities in
india because of the fact that they have
lived and developed in different
cultural environments
these suleimani speak arabic and carry
many yemeni arabic cultural traits
in many ways and not some of those
indian sometimes hindu influences that
we find in the
border communities the solemnities are
currently led by their
dayal watlap called abdullah ibn
muhammad
and that's the thing aside from some
minor cultural differences that we have
discussed
the only main difference between these
different branches
is that they follow different chief dyes
or leaders
when it comes to the practices or
beliefs of these communities the taibi
smileys generally are pretty uniform
the taibis see themselves as heirs to
the fatimids and their doctrines often
relate back to that imperial period
of course the nizodia smileys also trace
their lineage to the fatimids but
it's perhaps even more emphasized by the
tibis
in terms of their practices they follow
a fatimid model of jurisprudence and
religious hierarchy
in terms of the shariah or islamic law
they follow the isma'ili school of as
laid down by
khaldi al-nu'man an important judge
serving under the early fatimid caliph
imams and who
wrote the monumental treatise and islam
which served as the standard work of
ismaili jewish prudence during the
fatimid period
and for the tibia smileys afterwards and
up to this very day
like other muslims they pray five times
a day and this is a place where i want
to nuance something i said in a previous
video i made about ismailism
where i stated that ismailis only pray
three times a day
this is true for the nizari smileys the
largest
branch of ismailism but it's not
necessarily true for the taibis for
example and so
just putting it up there that's
something that
that's a nuance that i think is needed
and that's a careless mistake on my part
while the nizadis pray in buildings
known as jamaat khanas
the taybi ismailis pray in mosques and
the bordas have a building called jamaat
khana but that's usually reserved for
more social gatherings
for eating food for example and is also
often
in connection to the mosque but the
prayer itself is
performed in the mosque an interesting
feature of this community
at least in terms of the borders in
india is that there are no
pulpits or minbars in the mosque this is
because there is no
communal khutba or preaching performed
on
friday prayers or for special festivals
like
what is common in sunni islam and in 12
or shiism
instead the taibis hold that such
practices can only take place
under a manifested imam which is not the
case for them today
the tabies also do pilgrimages to mecca
and
give alms or zakat all parts of the
often described pillars of islam a
common practice as for many other
shiites
is to visit the graves or shrines of the
imams including those of ali and
hussain also like other shiites one of
the most important events of the year is
muharram
the month when several practices and
events take place in memory of the
martyrdom of the grandson of the prophet
and the third imam
hussein this events include various
gatherings and other activities that are
meant to remember
the suffering and sacrifice of hussein
and his family
and when it comes to the theological and
philosophical beliefs of the taybees
things get very interesting they are
muslims and so they hold the basic
tenets of islamic belief they are
monotheists they believe in
one god they believe that muhammad is
the messenger
of this god and so on they also thus
rely on the quran
as the primary source for all things
religion
as well as at least certain hadiths
being shiites they also place an
enormous emphasis on the imams as
successors to the prophet muhammad and
their teachings as well as
place in world history when it comes to
the doctrinal beliefs of these
communities it's rather difficult to say
because most of the books
and literature is hidden away in
libraries that are not
available to outsiders including
scholars
but we know that in the yemenite period
before the
split into the three current branches of
the community
the taibi dais and scholars produced and
developed its esoteric teachings
being ismailis the taibis are indeed
characterized by a great esotericism
and influence from philosophical schools
like neoplatonism
they place a great emphasis on the botan
the hidden or esoteric
aspects of religion and the quran
alongside
its zaher or open manifest or literal
aspects the thebes in yemen read studied
and commented on works by
earlier ismaili writers including the
mysterious ichuanes safa
the brethren of purity as well as daes
like hamid adin al-kirmani
the latter thinker kirmani differed in
his philosophical
writings from the usual neoplatonic
model by adopting a cosmology of ten
different intellects that descend from
the absolute
transcendent one that is god kirmani's
writings appear to have been especially
influential for the thebes
as a result of this we find a very
unique and complex metaphysical and
cosmological scheme
that is sometimes very reminiscent of
what is often termed
gnosticism the second dae el motlach on
the tabis
introduced a cosmological quote-unquote
drama in heaven as the scholar farhad
daftari puts it
in this cosmic drama the different
intellects or
beings in the celestial world the
spiritual world
become ranked into ten separate
intellects
but the third of these intellects is
unhappy with his position
and wants the place of the second higher
intellect the
universal soul thus being of a higher
rank and closer to
the one as originator as a result of his
arrogance this
third intellect is then punished by
falling down to instead occupy the
10th and lowest rank then
it is this intellect that acts as a
creator or
demiurge of the manifest universe which
is not surprisingly
seen as an inferior world in this
inferior
created world some fallen beings are
inclined towards the higher world of
spirits and the so-called
universal adam another name for the
tenth intellect
while others are inclined towards evil
represented by iblees or
the devil world history is then divided
into various
cycles all of which contain different
prophets as well as kaaims who appear at
the end of each cycle
in so-called minor resurrections to
ascend to the place of the 10th
intellect so world history is as i said
divided into these various cycles and at
the end of each cycle there appears
a kaaim akaim is a kind of messianic
figure
that is awaited by muslims and and
shiites
in particular they will sort of end
the current cycle and bring about the
day of resurrection in this case a minor
day of resurrection a minor day of
judgment
and after this event this call-in will
then
ascend to the place of the tenth
intellect
and the previous tenth intellect would
then ascend to one step
above that so he'll become the ninth
intellect
and this gradual ascent continues
through the different cycles
until the great resurrection the
priyamat al-qiyamat
at the end of all time when the tenth
intellect the one who
fell down to or was punished and fell
down
will finally have ascended enough to
once again reunite with and
be on equal rank with the second
intellect
which concludes this drama in heaven
you can tell it's a very complex
metaphysical scheme
they view the material world as
something inferior
something not necessarily negative but
certainly are something that should be
neglected and instead the focus should
be on the
spiritual world of the intellect a very
near platonic
very you could call it gnostic even that
though that's a problematic term
it has affinities with many of these
different
intellectual and religious traditions uh
from antiquity and other periods
but many of these features including the
more complex
scheme of the ten intellect and so on
differ them from the earlier smileys who
are more
pure neoplatonists as well as
to differ them from the nazades again
which is the largest
group of ismailis today these
philosophical ideas and doctrinal
tendencies have
by all accounts still remained important
to the tabies until today
even though most regular people probably
don't
debate and discuss the intricacies of
the cosmic drama on a
daily basis but as i said it's hard to
say anything definitive about these
groups because their writings are not
accessible
to outsiders the boras in india are a
bit more
visible and accessible but they also
practice a kind of secrecy when it comes
to their doctrines and their writings
these surleimanis in yemen are even more
isolated and we don't know much about
them at all
some estimates show that there may be
around 70 thousand suleimanies living in
yemen
while as i said the daodiboras in india
might be close to a million
but all of them as representatives of
the larger taibi branch of ismailism
make up a unique expression of shiism
and
islam more generally it's always good to
learn about the incredibly diverse ways
that a major religion like islam can
manifest
itself in to show the complexity of
religious identity
and history the daodi and alawi boras
and suleimanis are branches of the
taibis
who are a branch of ismailism a branch
of shiism
which is yet another branch of islam
they have a long and
deep history of intellectual and
political activity
and are often active players in the
contemporary world especially the boras
in india
they traced their intellectual religious
lineage and heritage to the
fatimids one of the great empires of
middle eastern history
and serve as another example of the
incredibly unique and fascinating
tradition
that is ismaili shiism don't forget to
check out hekma history and his series
on the fatimids to get a proper
historical context for some of these
subjects
and make sure to subscribe to his
wonderful channel
i hope you found this rather complicated
dive into the history and ideas of
tayabi ismailism
at least somewhat understandable and
interesting
i look forward to hearing your opinions
in the comments
if you want to support the channel as
always you can become a patron or you
can
like and comment on the video or as
always
just subscribe to the channel and i will
see you next time
[Music]
you